it's great to welcome to the program
today Cade Crockford who's the director
of the technology for liberty program at
the ACLU of Massachusetts Cade great to
have you on I appreciate it thanks for
having me so I want to talk about
biometric surveillance facial
recognition and how law enforcement may
or can use these technologies but first
you know recently on the program I had
someone call in and talk about hey david
hasn't what we mean by a right to
privacy been drastically altered by the
technologies that exist today in the
sense that a hundred years ago in public
legally you might have had a very
similar set of rights and laws as you
have today but in practice a lot of the
technologies that exist today and didn't
a hundred years ago have changed what it
means to be anonymous or to be in
private or in public what should our
understanding of this be under the law
but then also kind of a more colloquial
understanding that's a great question
people need to remember that in a
democracy and our society is ostensibly
a democracy we the people are in charge
not corporations or government agencies
like the FBI so we have the power at
least theoretically to determine how new
technologies ought to impact our right
to privacy to enemity even in public
space so I just want to remind folks
that the Constitution the way that it's
interpreted by the courts is merely a
floor it is not a ceiling so in other
words we could certainly if we wanted to
pass laws prohibiting corporations from
selling our cell site location
information that's the information
revealing where we've been where we've
traveled with our cell phones in the
past we could do that it just requires a
political will we certainly could
prohibit or severely restrict the
government from using technologies like
facial recognition and public space
that's merely a political problem it's
not a technological problem so certainly
technology has changed the degree to
which both corporations and governments
can create really comprehensive records
of our movements our activities our
associations our interests but that's
not necessarily inevitable it is merely
because we have not taken the necessary
political steps to ensure that our
technology does not outpace the law with
respect to our privacy protections and
when we start to look at the ways in
which law enforcement use or utilize
some of these technologies we've talked
about everything from the I believe
they're called stingray a cell tower of
sort of replicators I may be lacking the
exact right vocabulary but the idea that
the police can have a device that your
cell phone will believe is just another
cell tower and connect to it and by
virtue of that you are passing a lot of
information on to law enforcement
biometric surveillance facial
recognition software we're going to get
into some of these specifics and where
they're being used but what is the
position of the ACLU generally speaking
about law enforcement's ability to use
these different technologies when a
warrant does not exist for the specific
surveillance of an individual so just as
a general matter the Fourth Amendment
provides for our right to privacy and
says essentially that unless you are
involved in criminal activity and the
government can show evidence of that
which is called probable cause to a
judge and get a warrant they shouldn't
be able to invade your privacy now as we
kind of discussed before there's an
active debate about what privacy means
in the 21st century so just as an
example a recent Supreme Court case that
was decided in the summer of 2018 last
summer called carpenter versus United
States is the most important privacy
ruling we've seen at the Supreme Court
in a long time and that case is
particularly important because it
disagreed with law enforcement
interpretation of the Fourth Amendment
which essentially was that when you go
out in public you have no rights
privacy so the court held in a very
important ruling in the carpenter line
and a decision written by Chief Justice
Roberts that in fact technology has
substantially changed the balance of
power between the government and the
people now you know in a free society in
a democracy the government ought to know
almost nothing about the general
population unless we've affirmatively
disclosed information to the government
to receive benefits or something like
that and we should know almost
everything about what the government is
doing new surveillance technologies and
unfortunately the post 9/11 hysteria
around terrorism has really flipped that
balance so now the government and this
is true of even local and state police
officers all the way up to the level of
the federal government at the FBI and
the DEA etc they can know almost
everything about us often without a
warrant and we know very little about
what they're doing because their
operations are shot in secrecy so the
carpenter' ruling is really important
because it's takes a very clear claim or
rather draws a line in the sand for 21st
century forms of service surveillance by
essentially saying it is vastly
different for law enforcement to use
technology like cell phone tracking you
know technologies like cells like
location information information that is
maintained on hundreds of millions of
people across the United States that is
qualitatively and quantitatively
different from law enforcement following
one person around to see where they're
going and this is an important concept
that we call friction right there are
only so many police officers in the US I
think there are too many they're about a
million but there are over 300 million
people in this country right and so it
would be physically impossible for law
enforcement to follow each one of us
around noting our every movement every
day of our lives
cell phone technology makes it possible
not only for law enforcement to see
where we are in the present moment and
on a mass scale but also to do something
that was previously impossible which is
to find out where we were three weeks
ago three months ago six months ago
before we were even under from
investigation or suspected of a crime
and so Chief Justice Roberts says that
because the technology facilitates a new
form of mass tracking that is not
possible without the technology the
government is required to get a warrant
even if they're merely tracking our
public movements even if they're not
tracking our private movements in our
home even if they're just tracking where
we go on public streets because previous
to the existence of this technology that
type of surveillance was actually not
even feasible so yes mass surveillance
is distinct from individualized targeted
surveillance that law enforcement is
engaged in because they believe that
someone is actually engaged in a crime
new technologies license plate readers
face surveillance technology certainly
cell phone tracking give the government
the power to very cheaply conduct
surveillance of hundreds of millions of
people's movements and activities and
again not just in the present moment but
actually reversing back in time to see
what we've been doing days weeks or
months before so let's now dig in a
little bit to the specifics of how some
of these technologies are being
implemented of different types of
biometric surveillance and facial
recognition where is it currently being
used so um there's a lot we don't know
unfortunately especially about what the
federal government is doing with face
surveillance technology by remote
biometric tracking technologies we view
as distinct from the traditional forms
of biometric surveillance that the
government has conducted including
fingerprints and DNA I mean there isn't
that iris scanning gait scanning so
that's the way that you walk is is also
a biometric which is which just means
something that's unique to each
individual of course our faces there's
even some science that says are the
shape of our ears is a biometric so
these new forms of biometrics that the
FBI has been experimenting with for
years now and that state and local law
enforcement are beginning to use to
track and identify people those are
distinct from fingerprints and DNA for
one simple reason
and we need to think of them as a class
as uniquely dangerous for this reason it
is necessary again this is back to the
concept of friction if law enforcement
wants to get my fingerprints or my DNA
they actually have to send someone
physically to follow me to pick up my
coffee cup or my cigarette but when I'm
thrown it on the ground or in the trash
to test that material that physical
material it is not possible yet maybe it
will be some David it's not possible yet
to pluck someone's DNA from a camera
that is you know coming from a satellite
in space it is easy trivial actually and
it's going to become even easier for
governments and corporations to collect
and store our biometrics
like our iris our face our ears the way
that we walk our gait remotely and
therefore and mass again this concept of
friction is really important you can't
have 1 million police officers
collecting 300 million people's DNA it's
simply impractical you can very easily
in the kind of China style surveillance
system that we're seeing in certain
regions of that country set up camera
networks that facilitate the mass
tracking of people through their
biometrics that are that are detectable
remotely so how is this happening again
we're not sure what's going on at the
federal level the FBI is very secretive
Congress has asked a lot of questions
that have gone on the answer to the of
the FBI
we aim to find out we filed a public
records request in January with against
the FBI and the Drug Enforcement
Administration asking them for
information about how they use these
technologies we're particularly
concerned about in the absence of any
regulation the FBI using these
technologies to track and monitor
dissidents at protests and places like
Standing Rock you know climate racial
justice anti-war anti-trump types of
activists and we do know however that
the FBI has access to 640 million images
of adults in the United States so that's
more obviously than every adult in the
country
essentially every single person with a
state identification card every person
who's been arrested is in a database
that's accessible to the FBI for facial
surveillance purposes that's pretty
terrifying and Congress has thus far
I've done nothing to stop it
we also know that at the local level
like for example here in Massachusetts
the driver's license state ID database
maintained by the Registry of Motor
Vehicles is basically a perpetual lineup
for law enforcement based around
searches so we know that since 2006
state and local and federal law
enforcement have been using that
database to conduct maybe fishing
expeditions pulling images from Facebook
when they want to identify someone and
running it against the arm these
database using facial recognition
technology to try to identify people
that's been happening without any
judicial oversight with no legislative
authorization no probable cause or even
reasonable suspicion is required by
police they don't have to demonstrate
that anybody is involved in a crime
before they can perform one of these
searches and so we're very concerned
that in the absence of any oversight or
accountability at the state level these
systems are being abused and misused
currently yeah I mean my you know any
time when I'm hearing about any policy
and someone presents a very
black-and-white view my instinct is to
be skeptical of that because like with
most things there are sort of things on
both side of the ledger so if we step
back for a moment from the legality I
could imagine that on the one hand this
is technology that can be used to not
only invade people's privacy in cases
when they actually haven't done anything
wrong but also misidentify people it
might disproportionately be inaccurate
with people from certain races jenos
right there's all sorts of things on the
bad side of the ledger on the other hand
there are probably some ways in which
this technology can lead to speedier
resolution of a crime or more quickly
finding a potential a violent person or
whatever it's all hypothetical but then
we get to what you're talking about
which is this seems to go beyond some of
the basic tenets of how law enforcement
is supposed to operate based on the
rules
have been established with regard to
warrants and probable cause and how
investigations have to be done and
that's where I feel like the concern
goes beyond merely evaluating whether
the ends are worthwhile yeah I mean
there in my view there are three
distinct ways that this technology can
be used one is to as I said before
perform an identification of someone so
say there's a dead person right
law enforcement find somebody dead in
the dead in a ditch they don't know who
this person is they're not carrying any
identification
they run the fingerprints the person's
never been arrested they're not you know
identifiable that way facial recognition
could be a valuable tool in that case
right you take a picture of the person's
face you run it against a database like
the Registry of Motor Vehicles to try to
find out who is this dead body there's a
second way that the technology can be
used which is vastly different which is
to supercharge effectively all of the
surveillance camera networks that exist
in our cities and towns across the
United States with automation technology
that makes it possible to you know in
the future the technology is not really
Marietta it doesn't quite work but it
will get better and in the future the
technology may enable government
agencies to type in your name David
Parkman hit enter and then automatically
the software will stitch together a
video showing every single place you've
been over the past five 10 years however
long the video is stored who you were
with what you were doing and prepare a
nice little report David Parkman was
seen outside the cannabis shop on this
date he was seen outside the Planned
Parenthood on this date he was seen at a
mosque on this date he was seen at a
protest on this day he was seen with a
whistle blower on this date right so
that type of surveillance is this stuff
that we're actually the most concerned
about and we think has no place in the
democratic society but it's actually
something that should just be banned
permanently we should never allow
government agencies to create
architectures are sort of surveillance
that facilitate that kind of mass
tracking of people in public space and
has no place in a free society so
there's there's a third way which is
also very scary
which is facial analysis technology so
this is technology that purports to be
able to discern whether someone is happy
or sad or anxious or stressed by
evaluating their face now a lot of its
junk science a really important research
paper was published by scholars at
Northeastern University including dr.
Lisa Behrendt who's a world-renowned
psychologist she reviewed over 2,000
papers in this area and found
essentially that due to cultural
differences you know people with autism
etc depending on the moods that they're
in at different contexts it is actually
not possible to discern how someone is
feeling by evaluating the physical
characteristics of their face so we are
very concerned that law enforcement
other government agencies will start to
adopt technologies that purport to be
able to tell police officers potentially
in a very high-stress dangerous
situation whether the person that
they're looking at is stressed has a
criminal record and you know may be
armed and dangerous and if the
technology gets stuff wrong in that kind
of context which we assume it will
because technology frequently gets
things wrong that could mean the
difference between life and death
for a human being walking on the streets
of an American city and so we want to
make sure again that those types of
facial analysis tools that are already
in relatively widespread use in the
commercial sector so for example in
remote job interviews they're doing
these over they're using these these
technologies over technologies like
Skype when you're applying for a job at
a large corporation we want to make sure
that government agencies are not using
those technologies to evaluate for
example in the interrogation room
whether someone's telling the truth or
not when they're talking to the police
so there are two categories of the
technology that we actually think should
never be adopted in a free society the
other the right like we have an image of
someone's face and we want to identify
this person I think that for example
with dead people potentially with
Alzheimer's patients and potentially in
very very you know specific criminal
investigations where there's a really
high risk to the public like for example
in a murderer
investigation with the appropriate level
of judicial oversight and transparency
and rigorous auditing and and public
oversight that that type of surveillance
may have a place in the 21st century but
there are some forums again that really
just shouldn't and we have the power
again in a democracy to draw that line
and say you know what Amazon and Jeff
Bezos have a certain idea of what the
future will look like we have a
different one and and we're going to
make sure that ours wins out we've been
speaking with Kate Crockford who's the
director of the technology for Liberty
program at the ACLU of Massachusetts
Kate thanks so much for talking to us
about this today I appreciate it thanks
a lot